[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
dimanche en politique sur france 3
bourgogne en annonçant une série de
mesures pour le pouvoir d'achat lundi
soir emmanuel macron a tenté de calmer
la colère des gilet jaune
un mois après le début de leur
mobilisation mézières certains moins
nombreux à paris pas forcément dans
notre région vous le verrez se sont
encore mobilisés alors sommes-nous en
train de sortir de la crise les
propositions des manuels macron sont
elles suffisantes assistons à un
tournant du quinquennat un virage social
le mouvement des gilet jaune at il un
avenir peut-être sur le terrain
politique
on en débat avec nos invités ce dimanche
en direct fadila khattabi bonjour vous
êtes député la république en marche de
côte-d'or
un mot sur ce qui s'est passé peut-être
d'abord hier à paris avec une
mobilisation qui est moindre est ce que
vous considérez que c'est une victoire
d'emmanuel macro et de ses propositions
de lundi soir ce n'est pas une victoire
je pense que ce mouvement qui est un
mouvement citoyen au départ qui ne fait
pas suite ni à un appel d'un parti
politique ni à une organisation
syndicale c'est vraiment un mouvement
citoyen avec des revendications fortes
notamment en matière de pouvoir d'achat
d'ailleurs je tiens à le dire on a été
élu emmanuel macron été élus sur cette
revendication très forte en terme de
pouvoir d'achat ça ne date pas
d'aujourd'hui d'ailleurs mais ceux qui
manifestent l'ombre a bien senti s'il ya
un volet il ya un tournant
le président a fait un certain nombre de
propositions très fortes en matière de
pouvoir d'achat qui réponde vraiment des
propositions qui répondent en termes de
pouvoir d'achat avec la suppression de
la csg notamment pour de la hausse de la
csg pour les petites routes et petites
retraites
les heures désocialisés supplémentaires
et défiscalisées la prime d'excellence
et voilà donc ce sont quand même
vraiment des mesures sans précédent qui
représente c'est ça qui explique que les
jeunes se sont moins mobilisés à paris
je pense que il
ils ont accepté la main tendue du
président de la république mais les
revendications sont tout aussi fortes il
ya une vraie attente il
un virage qui est pris je pense que
vraiment on assiste un moment très
important il y aura avant et après mais
le après vraiment sera tout aussi
important notamment concernant le
dialogue social qui doit se faire le
dialogue démocratique et c'est par là
qu'il faut poursuivre on va y venir
évidemment excuses et l'autre volet des
revendications des gilet jaune à la 2d
bonjour vous êtes membre des gilet jaune
en saône et loire vous avez quitté
provisoirement le rond point du mas ni à
côté de montceau-les-mines où vous où
vous vous mobilisez depuis de nombreux
mois a depuis de nombreuses semaines par
dont alain segaud vous vous gardez quoi
de la journée d'hier
il ya eu une mobilisation en saône et
loire une mobilisation à dijon qui
semble-t-il ne faiblit pas à paris elle
faiblit qu'est ce que vous en pensez
en ce qui concerne moi je parlerai que
pour le manier elle est aussi forte
qu'au début on a senti une forte
mobilisation et non une démobilisation
je pense que le pur pour les gens du
manier enfin la région de montceau il
est hors de question de date arrêtée
paris je ne sais pas à pas ce que j'ai
entendu c'est qu'il y avait quand même
des blindés tout autour et la remercie
dernière oui oui qui empêchait
apparemment l'accès du centre je pensais
aussi qu'on voyait moins de monde le
sait pas mais vous pouvez comprendre que
certaines nous et bien sûr proposition
d' emmanuel macron effet faiblir un
petit peu le moment parce qu'ils se
disent ah ben il a il a quand même fait
un geste d'accord alors on va y venir
après on peut revenir après mes romans
quand j'ai entendu ce matin j'ai entendu
on parlait de deux que tous les smicards
à les toucher et 100 euros
c'est faux c'est avec moi c'est faux
c'est pas on a 20 millions de smicards
il n'y aura pas 20 millions de personnes
qui est rond 100 euros déjà faut le
savoir puisque c'est en plus c'est sur
la prime de l'activité les huitièmes il
y sera calculé en fonction des revenus
aussi donc tout le monde ne percevra pas
et on a déjà il faut retrancher aussi
les vins les 20 euros de charges de
baisse de charges fiscales
donc il nous reste 80 où on va on va y
revenir dans un instant à toutes ces
propositions les effets d'annoncé sont
terribles dans la démobilisation
pas forcément bon pour votre mouvement
tout en l'occurrence c'est votre votre
point de vue le taf et jean-françois
farag bonjour vous êtes maire sans
étiquette je précise de blanot en saône
et loire vous être président des maires
ruraux de saône et loire les vous avez
d'ailleurs publié un communiqué il ya
quelques jours pour faire des
propositions vous aussi et d'ailleurs
les maires sont invités à ouvrir leur
mairie pour recueillir de forme de
cahier de doléances en quelque sorte
comment est ce que vous regardez ce qui
s'est passé hier
bah écoutez en proximité moi je passe à
mâcon nord bon je compte pas le nombre
de gilet jaune à chaque fois que je
passe à mâcon nord parce que j'y passe
assez souvent mais j'ai pas noté une
décrue une simple qu'ils étaient aussi
nombreux que les jours précédents est
bon parfois je discute deux ou trois
minutes avec eux ou un peu plus j'ai
l'impression quand même qu'ils sont très
mobilisés et qui sont pas sur le retrait
et qui n'ont pas forcément envie de
rentrer à la maison tout de suite est-ce
que vous qui êtes président des maires
ruraux vous noté du coup une différence
entre ce qui peut se passer à paris et
la réalité de ce qu'on vit en région sur
ce constat très locale j'ai pas eu
l'impression d'une baisse du mouvement
et puis alors ce qui se passe au donc ça
se voit moins
c'est qu'on a effectivement des
habitants qui viennent dans nos mairies
moi j'ai un maire qui me disait hier
donc il a le maire de claix c'est en
saône et loire
il a reçu quelqu'un qui lui a apporté
une contribution de 4 pages quand même
structure et sur un certain nombre de
soucis qu'ils sont qui sont les siens et
donc je pense qu'il ya un malaise au
delà des carrefours et de ce convoi il
ya un malaise qui est quand même très
profond et puis qu'il va falloir traiter
on va y revenir bien sûr philippe texier
bonjour vous êtes le secrétaire régional
de la cgt en bourgogne franche comté
alors vous qui êtes un habitué des
mouvements sociaux qui savez bien
comment comment ça fonctionne les
ressorts notamment des mobilisations des
manifestations votre point de vue sur ce
qui s'est passé il ya ce qu'on est à un
tournant de la mobilisation
en fait il s'est passé
une journée importante encore hier et
avant-hier vendredi puisque vous savez
que la cgt dr essoh syndicale a appelé à
une journée de mobilisation à c'est plus
de 100 milles au niveau national et sur
la région ces deux mille huit cents
manifestants salif et station distincts
de saab gilet jaune précisons le voile
c'est à dire qu'en fait le gouvernement
macron a devant lui
le mouvement des jeunes et jaune et un
mouvement syndical qui est enclenché
depuis plusieurs mois et qui a déjà mis
en lumière un certain nombre de
réactions de la part de nos de nos
syndicats et qui ont permis à des
salariés de s'exprimer sur la réforme de
la santé la réforme ferroviaire la
réforme de la formation professionnelle
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que vous
estimez qu'il peut qu'on est à un point
où il peut y avoir une convergence des
luttes
la fameuse convergence des luttes la
convergence des luttes c'est pas quelque
chose qui se décrète on peut on peut on
peut on peut souhaiter que tous ceux qui
qui ont des intérêts communs se
rassemblent et certainement que
d'ailleurs on assiste dans certains
rangs poids des contacts de la part de
nos syndicats avec un certain nombre de
gilet jaune
certes un gilet jaune ne souhaite pas
nous rencontrer nous met à l'écart parce
que je pense que c'est ce qui
caractérise leur mouvement un mouvement
apolitique et donc en dehors des singes
il ya cependant je pense que ce
mouvement lui a une portée politique et
en fait je pense que les gilets jaunes
dans les contacts dans le mouvement sont
en train d'envoyer des messages forts
c'est aujourd'hui des questions de
démocratie
y compris leur appréciation des
premières mesures de macron on voit bien
que ne convainc pas parce que je pense
qu'au fil des discussions des débats il
ya une politisation et je pense que
balijon ne comprennent que macro est en
train de se moquer d'eux mais vous vous
savez bien qu'à un moment donné dans un
conflit vous êtes bien placé pour le
savoir que à un moment donné on sort
souvent par le haut et c'est une affaire
de compromis les conflits sociaux non
mais pour qu'il ya un compromis
il faut qu'ils aient une négociation et
et qu'on s'entende sur les termes de à
moment donné à la fois ceux qui sont en
responsabilité pour mener une politique
là ici le gouvernement mais aussi d'un
chef d'entreprise lorsqu'il s'agit de
revendications d'entreprise réussissent
à tomber d'accord sûr que le produit la
négociation est quelque chose qui permet
d'accepter le terme du conflit
là il semble qu'on n'est pas dans cette
situation là puisque l'on touche à la
fois des revendications sociales et
vient pointer des revendications d'ordre
politique
je pense par exemple à ce que j'ai
entendu les références les référendums
définition remise en cause du
gouvernement là on est sur des questions
clés nationale de l'assemblée nationale
voire voire du président lui-même
là ce sont des jeux dirait des des
questions qui viennent et qui ont été le
produit de discussions au sein des gilet
jaune
fadila khattabi on a vu que les
propositions évolué c'est à dire qu'a eu
des propositions sur le pouvoir d'achat
qui ont été faites
effectivement par les gilets jaunes
depuis depuis un certain nombre de temps
et il y a eu derrière effectivement des
propositions des annonces des manuels
macron et on peut aussi noter ensuite
que il y a eu de nouvelles propositions
sur le plan plus démocratique et là on
imagine que les maires et les élus
locaux ont aussi un rôle à jouer
bien sûr mais je voudrais rebondir par
rapport à ce que dit monsieur texier
pour qu'il y ait effectivement dialogue
et négociation il faut aussi être autour
de la table pour aujourd'hui moi je les
ai rencontrés les gilets jaunes à ma
permanence sur le terrain à crimolois où
j'ai passé pratiquement de plus de deux
heures avec eux vendredi encore ils sont
venus certains ont laissé tomber le
gilet jaune
en bas on va voir maintenant il faut se
mettre autour de la table et on va
essayer de négocier un certain nombre de
choses
les corps intermédiaires - effectivement
un rôle important à jouer on l'a vu
quand on n'a pas de représentant comment
voulez-vous négocier quand vous n'avez
personne manuel mac on le découvre un
petit peu à ses dépens que les
cormeilles intermédiaires ont un rôle à
jouer parce que ces messieurs qui sont
autour de la table aujourd'hui les élus
locaux et aussi les syndicats patronaux
ou deux salariés ont été un peu mis sur
la touche pendant les deux premiers 18
premiers mois non jean-françois santé
mais délégués des mers rue démerder
notamment des maires ruraux que je jure
que je représente
bon il ya depuis 18 mois des
propositions cantillon qui ont été
faites d'aider des choses qui ont été
exprimés et l'association des maires
ruraux n'a pas le sentiment d'avoir été
entendu et pire on a continué à
détricoter la commune puisqu'il ya des
compétences de plus en plus ce qui
inquiétait qui était locale et donc on
détricote la commune on affaiblit le
rôle du maire et ça ça ça fini ça finit
par questionner beaucoup les beaucoup
les collègues est bon maintenant on leur
demande de jouer ce rôle peut-être de
médiation des coûte donc je pense que
les maires sont prêts à le jouer mais
veillons à ne pas déstabiliser
complètement cet échelon de proximité
qui justement est le peut-être le moins
critiquer ce corps intermédiaires on va
dire que c'est un corps intermédiaires
les lmr mais ce corps de 7,7
cette proximité qui est peut-être la
moins critiquée par rapport à la
représentation nationale par rapport à
la à la haute administration qui est
jugé très très éloignées des
préoccupations locales
donc arrêtons de dévitaliser ce niveau
communal je crois que c'est important à
la souris est-ce qu'il ya est ce que
c'est un pack complet les les
revendications des gilets jaunes
selleria ses parties de la question d'
attaque du carburant pour arriver aux
questions de pouvoir d'achat
et aujourd'hui il ya toutes ces
questions démocratiques on a beaucoup
entendu parler de référendum
d'initiative citoyenne hier pas
forcément je veux dire par là que moi je
quand j'ai mis le gilet jaune s'était
pas
c'est pour la taxe spécialement pour la
taxe ça fait si vous voulez très
longtemps que je me plains depuis des
des gouvernements successifs et qui nous
matraque par des taxes hélas si vous
voulez ça faisait longtemps que la
marmite bouillait hélas le couvercle a
sauté
je trouve quand même que depuis très
longtemps comme je le dis des taxes nous
écrase ça fait un moment que l'état vit
au dessus de nos moyens et avions eu les
moyens
excusez moi mais les tous les élus
vivent je trouve au dessus de nos moyens
ça veut dire que il bénéficie quand même
davantage assez considérable j'en veux
parler
parlons aussi des présidents de la
république qui coûte 2 millions un peu
plus de 2 millions de parents et pas
ancien président de la république
d'autres parlementaires qui ne qui sont
en retraite qui bénéficient de voitures
de fonction qui ont des gardes du corps
qui ont des trajets en train voire un
avion ça ce sont des choses que j'ai été
interpellées notamment par exemple sur
nos frais de mandat que nous avions
retirer la csg c'est joliment scandaleux
ce que je veux dire là je tiens à
expliquer c'est que les frais de mandat
ce sont des frais professionnels et
comme tous les frais professionnels
il n'y a pas de siéger sur les frais
professionnels pour n'importe quelle
entreprise jean vautrin dénoncé
l'inéquité sûr concernant su elle n'a
pas été retirée nous payons là csg sur
notre année de mythe et concernant la
retraite nous sommes les premiers
députés la république en marche à avoir
effectivement faire en sorte que notre
retraite soit aligné avec celle de tous
les français
l'assemblée nationale a voté monsieur la
voter nous n'avons aucun privilège à ce
niveau là parce que beaucoup m'ont dit
madame vous faites un mandat et vous
avez mille 600 euros de retraite pour un
mandat
faux archi faux je dis aux citoyens il
faut faire très attention
il y a beaucoup de fake news et sur les
réseaux la coincer ministre ont renoncé
c'est la petite augmentation qu'ils
allaient avoir au mois de janvier il
trouvait que ça sonnait mal à comprendre
la moindre des choses
moi j'ai vous voulez j'ai regardé avant
de venir le le salaire si vous voulez
alors député 7209 brut privilège député
5000 euros mensuels pour le frais de
mandat
dix-huit mille neuf cent cinquante euros
par an une enveloppe 15500 au début pour
l'achat de matériel
ces chiffres mais moi je veux bien
justifier tous mes frères monsieur tous
mes frais j'ai une permanence qui me
coûte plus de 1400 euros par mois j'ai
défriché des prétentieux non j'ai des
frais de fonctionnement
s'il n'y avait pas les mêmes indemnités
les maires ruraux bon souvent c'est en
et communes de moins de 500 habitants
sekkat ou 500 euros par mois
certains d'ailleurs certains certains
mettent prennent un niveau d' indemnité
inférieure divise par deux ce qui est ce
qui est possible
donc c est si vous regardez le nombre
d'heures bon c'est du quasi bénévolat
c'est quasi mais voilà pour les
meilleurs alors pour revenir à un plan
général plus générale je pense quand
même que ce qu'on entend dans ce
mouvement
c'est il ya une demande de sobriété il
ya une demande de sobriété des
institutions de plus grande sobriété et
je pense qu'il faut il faut faire
attention les collectivités publiques à
tous les niveaux dans leur
fonctionnement dans les cocktails qui
sont organisées dans l'est dans les
toutes ces pratiques et la crise youn
mans les dépenses publiques les dépenses
les dépenses de fonctionnement doivent
être plus sobre et il faut il faut il
faut on en arrive à une question il faut
il faut être exemplaire c'est à dire
qu'un élu doit être exemplaire dans son
est compris dans son mode de vie
personnelle et
je crois que c'est une demande qui est
très très forte et les citoyens veulent
savoir où passe l'argent public alors
qu'en et c'est sur les chiffres est allé
chercher ça témoigne de la pression
emmanuel macron dans son intervention de
lundi soir en quelque sorte entendu cet
appel à la sobriété il ya même eu un mea
culpa 23 millions de français ont suivi
le 13 mai les 13 minutes d'allocation
d'allocutions télévisées du président de
la république c'est dire la tente d'un
pays qui se demandent ali jour de noël
si la sortie de crise est en vue je vous
propose d'écouter les propositions
résumé du chef de l'état c'est d'abord
l'état d'urgence économique et sociale
que je veux décrété aujourd'hui avec
quatre mesures pour relancer le pouvoir
d'achat et en premier lieu une
revalorisation du smic le salaire d'un
travailleur au smic augmentera de 100
euros par mois dès 2019 sans qu'il en
coûte 1 euro de plus pour l'employeur
deuxième mesure une annulation de la
hausse de la csg pour une partie des
retraités pour ceux qui touchent moins
de 2000 euros par mois nous annulerons
en 2019 la hausse de csg subi cette
année l'effort qui leur a été demandé
était trop important pour les salariés
les charges sociales sur les heures
supplémentaires seront supprimés dès
janvier et non septembre 2019 les heures
supplémentaires seront versés sans
impôts ni charges et 2019 enfin pour les
salariés emmanuel macron confirme la
défiscalisation d'une prime
exceptionnelle qui pourrait être versé
par les entreprises à leurs salariés une
prime qui n'est pas obligatoire pour les
patrons je demanderai à tous les
employeurs qui le peuvent de verser une
prime de fin d'année à leurs employés et
cette prime n'aura à quitter ni impôts
ni charges
philippe texier pour la cgt quand vous
entendez toutes les propositions des
manuels macron qui certes on l'a compris
on a entendu alain segond à neu neu ne
satisfont pas une partie des gilets
jaunes mais vous dites pas à nous
nous les syndicats on a rarement obtenu
autant après une mobilisation surtout
c'est que nous on n'a pas à revendiquer
que le smic soit augmentée sur la hausse
de la prime d'activité est là en fait le
gouvernement fait un cadeau aux petits
patrons qui étaient mobilisés avec les
gilet jaune et donc qu'il donne il donne
un exemple alors qu'il faudrait remonter
le smic c'est à dire le taux horaire
pour donner une base à une
revalorisation dans les entreprises des
qualifications de l'ancienneté
en fait il ferme la porte elle incite
les employeurs à ne pas augmenter si on
y rajoute la mesure donc des heures
supplémentaires désocialisés
défiscalisées en fait on augmente le
temps de travail ont réduit éléments de
fait les recettes de la sécurité sociale
est évidemment du budget de l'état j'en
oublie c'est quoi c'est un tour de passe
passe et c'est la poubelle sernam 100%
une expérience et un beau coup
moralement qu'ils appliquent de façon un
peu précipité puisqu'il avait annoncé
dès son installation en fait il fait un
cadeau au patronat
et il incite toutes les petites
entreprises mais les petites entreprises
en ont peut-être besoin mais bien sûr
mais les petites entreprises à ce moment
là il faut revoir l'ensemble de la
fiscalité
et quand j'entends tout à l'heure la
discussion qui a qui rentrent vous sur
le fait qu attention le gouvernement
enfin l'état de revenir à plus de
sobriété
je crois qu'il faut pas ce simplement se
se cacher y compris il peut y avoir une
sensibilité pour ceux qui souffrent le
plus en fait à l'outrance de certains
mais surtout ce qu'il faut regarder
c'est qu'on a une fiscalité qui est
injuste un autre pays
sur près de 260 milliards de recettes
pour l'état peut quasiment plus de la
moitié sont de la tva qui va frapper à
la fois le smicard le sans emploi ou le
très riche donc là mon avis à regarder
et spécialités est vraiment une
fiscalité plus progressive et qui
permettent de financer les services
publics entendent aussi les gilet jaune
sont d'accord avec ce que dit la cgt
finir je crains que derrière ces mesures
se cache une réduction des services
publics sur la fiscalité tout à fait
d'accord et quand j'entends le président
dira
100 euros pour tous les smicards pour
tous les sévices et faut naturellement
puisqu'il ya 20 millions de smicards et
la mesure d'en toucher normalement 2
millions 6 alors ce sont les gens qui
font la demande pour le revenu qui vont
la prime d'activité voilà merci et une
question je vais poser deux mille euros
c'est 2000 euros par personne au par
couple non par personne c'est par
sessegnon pour une personne seule
ces 2000 euros à la pour la retraite
pour l'instant nous sommes nous serons
amenés à travailler cette semaine pour
effectivement faire en sorte de mettre
en musique tous toutes les annonces du
président de la république nous avons
échangé beaucoup sur le fil mais je fais
partie de la commission des affaires
sociales donc l'avoir levé en partie de
cette commission là et bien sûr de la
commission des finances
donc ensuite effectivement il va falloir
mettre en oeuvre tout cela donc à ce
jour le présenter au public ses 2000
euros pour une personne et pour un
couple effectivement c'est 3000 ou 3300
donc nous sommes en train de travailler
là j'ai pour toucher l'amérique ne pas
pour pau non suppression assez
impressionnant pour un couple c'est
combien alors jusqu'à 3 300 euros
la chaussure la défiscalisation je pense
que bon effectivement pour les gens qui
avaient des problèmes bien sûr pour les
gens non mr la défiscalisation des
heures sup
alors pour les gens qui en bénéficient
c'est bien mais il ya une déclaration de
monsieur castaner quand il était maire
ps mais la vérité d'hier n'est pas celle
d'aujourd'hui
monsieur castaner déclaré monsieur
castetner déclaré ce les ifs les lycéens
finition et la défiscalisation des
heures sup ça coûte 4 milliards et ça
supprime 600 mille emplois ça c'est ce
qui est déclaré en me en 2013
monsieur que sa mère monsieur castaner
va certainement voter cette loi je pense
je suppose des endroits le changer la
vie
aujourd'hui moi ce que je voudrais dire
c'est qu'au si c'est une question de
confiance même si effectivement le
mouvement des gilets jaunes apporte un
certain nombre de revendications mais
malgré tout moi je suis aussi sur le
terrain on me dit certaines choses on a
recréé des emplois industriels plus de
10000 les investisseurs étrangers
reviennent en france il ya une confiance
qui est en train de s'installer
donc profitons aussi de cela pour faire
en sorte maintenant de dialoguer de
mettre tous les corps intermédiaires
autour de la table et d'avancer moins de
cinq minutes de mission on voit aussi
qu'il ya un déficit de lien entre les
élus et le peuple comment on change ça
les demandes de référendum d'initiative
citoyenne les demandes d'élection à la
proportionnelle les doigts est ce que
c'est un terrain sur lequel maintenant
vous la république en marche vous allez
avancé aussi cités suite aux débats il y
aura un certain nombre de décisions à
prendre
donc nous les prendrons nous prendrons
bien sûr nos responsabilités mais ce qui
est aussi important c'est aussi de créer
des liens avec aussi les représentants
les représentants locaux les
représentants nationaux les
organisations syndicales
il ya rien de pire que de n'avoir
personne en face avec qui négocier et ça
vous l'avez appris à vos dépenses et le
redit mais pendant 18 mois jean françois
parent qui l'attendait comme étions
effectivement la tête dans le guidon
avec les réformes des réformes qui était
aussi jean françois parent comment vous
vous allez pouvoir jouer un rôle je
parlais de ses cahiers de doléances en
début d'émission ouverts dans les
mairies
est-ce que vous allez reprendre la main
en quelque sorte puisque vous êtes les
élus préférés des français entre
guillemets les maires oui alors je pense
que les élus peuvent reprendre la main
de prendre la main ou continuer à
prendre la main de deux façons parce que
bon ce que mon ce que disent beaucoup
les maires aujourd'hui c'est que
l'écoutent quotidienne les maires dans
la proximité ont fait ça tout le long de
l'année
bon certains m'ont dit bon cahier de
doléances pourquoi pas mais on fait ça
tout le monde l'a toulon d'année alors
bon il ya l'écoutent et là des citoyens
des habitants vous allez faire monter et
ensuite il faut faire remonter ça il
faut faire remonter ce à tous les
niveaux
ça peut être au département ça peut être
au préfet je pense que les préfets
pourraient jouer un rôle un peu plus
grand et ne pas être uniquement en ligne
avec le le gouvernement mais faire
remonter des choses vous pensez que les
mères peuvent avoir un rôle à jouer est
ce que vous avez plus confiance dans les
mers que dans les élus nationaux ou les
hauts fonctionnaires plus près des mères
que des élus s'étaient déjà envoyé moins
de chance au rond point qui vient de
voir
il en est venu oui oui on en a vu on a
bu le maire de bon sur le verre de
sanvignes est venu faire du warhol dans
cette la relation s'explique c'est pas
suffisant lorsque vous parlez de
d'interlocuteurs paraît qu'on a on est
réfractaire aux réformes non non non des
réformes
ça va on ergote oui tout à fait mais on
est riche parterre aux réformes que l'on
nous propose des réformes je vous en
propose et je vous propose des réformes
fait ses propositions je discute tout de
suite suppression des niches fiscales
pour les grandes entreprises qui peuvent
ne pas payer d'impôt en faisant
d'énormes bénéfices sur le territoire
100 milliards pas fait rentrer 100
milliards déjà bawin on est rentré mais
le président la ligue lega fort n'a pas
la réponse google ne payent pas d'impôts
madonna ne paye pas d'impôts c'est
scandaleux bon suppression des niches
fiscales suppression de certains
avantages fiscaux comme je vous disais
ou de certains avantages pour des élus
ou nous coûter cher
je m'intéresse pas spécialement vous
véritable chasse à la fraude fiscale
connaissent team entre 80 et 60
milliards contre 60 pendant 80 milliards
taxer les transactions boursières qui
n'apporte rien c'est de l'argent virtuel
rapidement oui oui à bienne ont parlé
eux mêmes une renationalisation des
autoroutes et des fdf
on a bradé on a bradé le patrimoine
français
on est en train laissez moi finir s'il
vous plaît chez je vais vous dire une
chose encore très vite très vite qu'on
est en train de privatiser on va
privatiser l'aéroport de paris qui
rapportent un milliard et demi par an
c'est à dire que l'étape encore se
priver d'un milliard et demi que nous
allons donc mettre la main à la poche
pour payer nous donner
les pistes pour trouver l'argent pour le
pouvoir la charge tafer et pourboires
avec cet argent qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est très simple on diminue par par dix
les charges des petites moyennes
entreprises des artisans commerçants on
enlève les charges et la plupart des
gens et là vous relancer l'économie kim
peek si vous avez l'impression que les
syndicats de salariés notamment on peut
avoir un rôle à jouer dans cette cette
nouvelle partie qui s'annonce maintenant
de dialogue finalement et de dialogue
démocratique notamment alors de le
dialogue si c'est celui que macron
initié depuis son élection
enfin je souhaite bon courage au maire
et à tous ceux qui vont essayer de
donner leur avis monsieur macron écoute
et il met en place ce qui l'a décidé
donc je suis très dubitatif sur cette
période qui s'ouvre sino qu'à élever
rapport de force en direction dans fait
de ceux qui ont envoyé un message qui
ont soulevé les inégalités moi je pense
que il y as besoin en avant de très vite
posé la question de l'évaluation des et
publics et des exonérations
merci merci merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat dans un instant le
point sur l'actualité régionale avec
arnaud lefebvre suivi de la partie
nationale de dimanche en politique
francis letellier rosso richard ferrand
le président de l'assemblée nationale
bon dimanche à tous sur france 3